a neighborhood struck by grief
after an explosion ripped through a
crowded kovit 19
ward saad lost his father who had been a
patient at the hospital
as well as his brother who had stayed by
his bedside to care for him
my father was about to recover they even
took him off the oxygen
and then the hospital burned down i lost
two of them
we couldn't rescue them the explosion at
baghdad's
hospital where around 120 patients were
treated for covid19
was likely caused by a poorly handled
oxygen cylinder
doctors say the facility lacks basic
equipment
including a central oxygen supply system
and that patient's relatives often
handled oxygen cylinders because of a
shortage of medical staff
muhammad was there to attend to his
elderly aunt when the blast went off
but he couldn't save her
everyone left behind the patients and
just ran out in a few seconds the entire
floor was ablaze with heavy fire
despite the risk of covid19 infection
there was no restriction on the number
of relatives allowed in the wards
which further increased fatalities
this is neglect from the hospital
because you shouldn't allow anyone to
enter
the family members are greater in number
than the patients inside the icu
witnesses say the emergency response was
slow
while iraq's human rights commission
told al jazeera the hospital lacked
adequate fire safety systems
we know very well that there is absence
of
occupational safety requirements absence
of
confronting such fire and such buildings
when we look at on the official reports
about
such entity we see there is no auto
extinguishing system or firefighting
system
the prime minister has ordered an
investigation
and has suspended several officials
including the minister of health and the
governor of baghdad the deadly fire at
the ibm al-khatib hospital has further
fueled public anger over the
government's handling of the coronavirus
pandemic
and for many it's a manifestation of the
deeply rooted corruption that has
crippled the healthcare sector
on sunday families began holding
funerals
but few have hoped for genuine
accountability from the government
or that the structural issues that lie
at the heart of such accidents
will be addressed simona faulting
al-jazeera
baghdad